you're back is there any move that
the cabin send you over
you must have done quite a service with
the debt if he's got hands to spare for
old barnabas
let's get to business yeah
our wind pump's broken down again and
we're running low on water
we're all out of parts so i can't fix
her up
can always search the ruins
i'll keep your stash safe
i'll keep an eye on this
hey got any more scrap metal
come see what's left of my wares
see you around
a good price on what i've got left
iron well spent
did you get the scrap perfect i'll get
the wind pump up and running in no time
well good news is i got the water smells
like a sewer
only about a 10-fold worse
well i haven't smelled something this
rotten since since i've cleared out a
dennis slith ages ago
there are loathsome reptiles make their
homes in swamps and dank caves they
should create a nasty poison into the
water that makes it drinkable for them
but nearly always fatal to us
i bet good iron there's a nest in that
cave that fuels our pomp
i'm too old for all this splunk and so i
need you to go down there and kill it
this key will open the cellar in the
shack behind me right by that accursed
riftgate it connects to the bowels of
the prison which should lead you to the
cave
find the slith matriarch that's likely
polluting our water supply and the
poison should clear out on its own
you do this
and all the devil's crossing will be
honoring your name with every glass
have you cleared out this open the
cellar and the shack behind me it
connects to the bowels of the prison
which should lead
foreign
foreign
ah
ah
foreign
so
[Music]
[Applause]
well
so
[Applause]
so
yes
what's up
any luck clearing out those slits
people are starting to beg me for water
i don't know how many more times i can
say it'll melt your guts before they
just rush me and take it well done once
i pump out the remaining poisoned water
the spring should be clean enough for
drinking
i'll make sure to let people here know
how much help you've been
they'll be grateful that they can get a
drink without dissolving their
intestines
one more thing take my rucksack useful
for hauling back scrap or whatever else
you come across i'm too old for that
stuff now